hi my name is aline present and your
mba student they don't speak
this class of 2018 and i was with
you we do the independent star inn
where we explore the creation of the use of
technologies to improve the
financial and credit system for  small and
medium rural producers
one of the problems is that there is a
need to invest more and more
in agriculture
but credit to these segments said
small and medium producers is very
scarce because they are super badly
located they usually don't have
much credit and mainly
banks and financial institutions just
lack data that can
help you so in this within this
concept we studied how
technology can help you solve
this problem for both sides to
reduce financial costs and increase
the line  that the lines of credit for
this segment of the market